the new zealand government's decision to
lock the country down two weeks ago was
met with shock and even ridicule in some
parts of the world
the prime minister jacinda ardern made
the announcement when just one new case
of covert 19 was found in the community
new zealand's first in six months in
that two-week period there have been 612
new infections and the peak of the
outbreak may have already passed today
there are 49 new cases of covert 19 to
report all of these are in auckland
obviously that's a further decline on
yesterday's daily case number
four fewer and is our lowest number of
cases in six days
it does provide a further reassuring
indication that our public health
measures are rapidly slowing the spread
of the virus the largest city auckland
where the outbreak started will remain
under lockdown for at least another two
weeks but for the rest of the country
restrictions will ease slightly allowing
some businesses to reopen under tight
rules around mask wearing and
contactless service this outbreak
started with new zealand's first case of
the delta variant which has seen big
increases in infections and deaths in
many countries to try to prevent that
happening here the government moved
quickly into a strict lockdown which
like last year in the early stages of
the pandemic appears to have worked
in contrast lockdown in australia's
worst affected state isn't working the
rules in new south wales aren't as
strict as new zealand's and vary in
different areas of the state
it's recording more than a thousand new
cases a day and there are concerns the
hospitals may not cope these patients
are some of the sickest we've ever seen
they require so much support and
monitoring and physical care we're in
layers of ppe sometimes for hours at a
time this is really physically hard work
in both countries the focus is also on
trying to recover from a slow start to
vaccinate as many people as possible
before the end of the year to speed up
the process australia announced an extra
500 000 doses of fisa vaccine will
arrive this week in a swap deal arranged
with singapore
australia will reciprocate and send half
a million doses to singapore later in
the year
new zealand's government says it may
secure a similar deal with another
country amid concerns its rapid increase
in vaccination rates is dwindling
supplies wayne hey al jazeera tauranga
new zealand